four
three two hello
everybody and welcome to the h3 podcast
live everybody's favorite version of the
podcast because ela's here
thank you i realized that we both look
like fifth element characters now
yeah i think that's awesome and i look
like this one guy with this hair
what was his name he's like the super
feminine muscle dude with poofy hair
that looked just like mine and he was
like so dumb
he asked him to throw him a ball and a
bomb and he rolled him like the cube
talk about ruby
ruby rod no no don't be right not
rhubarb
um blonde blonde good lucky
muscle idiot from fifth element
here thank you keemstar appreciate that
um can somebody
can somebody do this for me thank you
anyway those who know
wake up you know you know today
of course oh you found it already amy oh
yeah this is him
thank you this is me look this is
important i know
but this is me yeah my hair is literally
exactly like his kind of cool like
short on the side poofy on the top
that's the vibe
oh that's hot everybody's like
you're making it cool thank you
and i see that zach is uh yeah you
didn't know solidarity yeah zach's in
solidarity
i'm trying to get simp yeah yeah i think
you earned that today
that was pretty good so and at any rate
um today we we come here to talk about
something sir oh today's
today's episode is sponsored by mint
mobile thank you
today we're here to talk about something
serious you know we're talking about
david dobrik a lot
wow oh well if you guys missed the memo
um we've been talking about david dobrik
a lot
and they responded actually specifically
one of the vlog squad members
scotty sire which with peace and love i
don't know anything about him but that
sounds like the name of a poodle
scottish saya scotty
okay scotty said you know shredder's
name was originally
right when we picked him up his name was
scotty like nah he ain't no scotty
yeah scott but yeah you were mine
yeah so scotty i guess and scotty
incidentally is like um
what say what scotty doesn't know is
that a song or something yeah
oh thank you dan thank you dan
thank you for that input well he doesn't
know actually because
he made this video
uh which in my opinion like i was like
okay either they're not gonna respond or
he's just gonna apologize to seth you
know which is the mature good thing to
do make a statement being like you know
what i was wrong
we used to do a lot of stuff back in the
day that wasn't okay and now i've grown
up i'm sure
well actually they put out a video
basically attacking and threatening seth
now this is scotty who's like the most i
guess
from what i understand because i'm not
super familiar with the vlog squad
dynamic
but everybody seems to like this guy
scotty and he has a really good
reputation among them
and so it seems to me that david used
this guy
and his good reputation to put out this
video to try to get the best response
and the reason i say that is because
scotty includes in his video a
clip of david david sent him a clip
of text messages of him with seth
and david is narrating it so clearly you
know
david knows he scottie's making this
video
and is supplementing him with
information so
this isn't just scotty's opinion this is
definitely david's opinion as well
which to me speaks volumes because
this was like the worst possible
uh response because
um it's like classic victim shaming
victim blaming victim dismissing
and now seth is actually getting just
a ton more [ __ ] and hate
and uh you know i i i messaged seth to
say hey do you want to
come in today to talk about it and at
first he was like yeah i'll come in and
then you know
um after a few hours
he said actually you know what i don't
want to go and talk about this
like on the record anymore it's getting
like and i'm assuming just because it's
just getting too crazy for him
especially because there was
insinuations in the video that david
could be seeking uh a legal right
yeah against me and right us too
yeah i mean the thought doesn't frighten
me at all but it but it would to
seth i mean i mean it still scares me
it's not anyone in it
i mean for a lawsuit it's it's not
something anyone wants to go through it
doesn't matter
like you know it's just such a ugly
process
expensive disgusting well i've already
been through one defamation lawsuit so
trust me i mean i've already defeated
one defamation lawsuit
you ain't [ __ ] you ain't winning
anything i'm not i'm not as scared as i
used to because we know so much more
now yeah but but even defending yourself
legally
is super successful so even if seth like
hypothetically has like a
iron-clad case it's still life-ruining
to get food
it's awful yeah so
they scared him and they and what
they're doing is scaring other people
you know i talk to other people who
have crazy things to say but they're
scared to come forward
and and stuff like this obviously
discourages
that further that is exactly why i
always laugh when people
try to say like about certain victims
when when it's like one person against a
famous person they
they always say oh it's just cloud
chasing it's like
you don't know how much [ __ ] they're
gonna get just for coming
out against someone who already has a
fan base yeah
the fans don't wanna hear that they
think they know this person and this
person is the best
what you'll see in scott scotty's video
so like this whole
immediate accusation that you always see
of like oh they're just doing it for the
fame they're just cloud chasing it's
like
no this is the worst way to get any
clout it just drives you away from
social media it drives away
away from everything because all you're
getting is just
more trauma basically that's what that's
what
uh seth said originally is that like he
wants to forget all this he doesn't want
to relive these moments you know what i
mean constantly
also something interesting to say about
scott as we watch his video
is that he is an investor in
dyspo which means he has a vested
interest
this is he has a vested interest in
maintaining david's good image
obviously now i'm not saying that had
anything to do with his responsibility
it's like i'm saying
conscious or unconscious you do have a
vested injury yeah i mean it's
it's a conflict of interest right uh
you know it's like you can't just come
out and defend you know
it says investor david just posted this
when he posted say be like a few days
ago on instagram
[Music]
it was from last week last week yeah so
scotty and jason and a lot of those guys
are investors
in dyspo so they all have a vested
interest
in protecting the brand and the image
and everything you know
so a conflict of interest for sure
worth definitely worth bringing up i
think
um
so i wasn't really sure how to respond
to this video exactly i'm just going to
play it and pause it
and respond as i i have so many thoughts
about this video there's so much i want
to say about it
um and i'm not really sure the best way
so i'm just gonna play it
and comment as uh as we go seth gave me
a comment to read
i'm gonna read it after we respond to
all this just because
um just because you'll have the full
context if you haven't yet seen his
video
because it alludes to certain parts of
his video and stuff
so let's just go ahead and watch uh
basically david dobrik respond via proxy
scotty i mean pretty much right listen i
was thinking to myself how funny would
it be
if whenever you got in [ __ ] you sent me
right by myself
i apologize for you that's exactly what
it is
i mean that's exactly what happened
because people like you more than me
so let's say i do something messed up
and i go ila can you go out there and
explain things
and then people are more receptive
because they like ela that's what
scotty's doing you know this just goes
to show how uh that just goes to show
how um disposable ain't just the name of
david's app it's how he thinks about his
friends
he's like send scotty out to the wolves
and also there's a lot of cult like
vibes that you'll pick up in this video
too
which is what big nick was saying is
that it's kind of culty and you'll see
that here
because scotty's one of the beautiful
people right he's one of the good
one of the he is he is right you know
what i mean
like he's one of the insiders he's one
of the cool kids
okay here we go what's up guys i am
totally sick of seeing my friends names
get dragged through the mud because of
false allegations and lies and just
things that aren't true so i'm going to
address some of those allegations and
defend my friends they haven't said
anything because typically the vlog
squad does not
address rumors and lies and gossip
because it platforms the person telling
the lies
draws attention to it and we know who we
are we know our character we know we're
good people and we know
it's not true but i thought already yeah
i mean i thought this was really
interesting
already setting the tone right i mean he
kind of gave something away when he says
that we don't platform lies
we don't respond because it platforms
them and it gives them attention
yeah what if they're not lying though
right right
but he but what he's actually giving
away is that they do have this
[ __ ] rule this happens kind of
frequently is what i'm getting
right and they have this spoken world to
just ignore ignore
don't give attention and it's all i mean
look all of it's untrue apparently
according to scotty by the way in the
very beginning he says
he says of seth again and this is why
people are going and [ __ ] on seth
what's up guys i am totally sick of
seeing my friends names get dragged
through the mud because of false
allegations and lies and just things
that aren't true so i'm gonna so he's
continue he always keeps referring to
these allegations by seth as false and
lies
yet you'll notice throughout the video
he does literally nothing to dispute
what seth said um i don't know how he
missed the point so badly man
guys draws attention to it and we know
who we are we know our character we know
we're good people and we know it's not
true do you mean we
this is gonna involve you that's the
other yeah we're good people we know who
you are
nobody's accusing you of anything like i
feel like maybe this
comes from a good place of you thinking
you're defending your friends but
it's just not right this isn't your
place to even
say something no one is talking about
you yeah but now you're coming
in and throwing more [ __ ] at the person
who's
got the false allegation apparently
based on why
is it false like you have it's not
including you
well the guys that are involved in it
should come and say something yeah the
fact that he's even responding to this
but this goes back to the cult like
thing it's like yeah we we
no no no no david is the one and jason
david is the one that's moving up david
is the one that's [ __ ]
uh blowing up as your channel i mean i
was kind of
whatever i'm not gonna yeah but but it's
not wee wee wee it's david david david
and he's using you yet again bro
and this has nothing to do with you and
somehow you're putting yourself in
in front and to shield david from like
this
these this onslaught of bullets and like
you didn't have to do that dude because
now you're in the [ __ ] mud
with him you didn't help him at all
you're just in the mud now with him
you know what i mean it's just even more
revealing of their whole
culture we're good people we're good
people so there's no way
by the way according to trisha that
scotty wasn't even involved in any of
this stuff he wasn't there during the
pranks he wasn't there during the seth
stuff
he barely knew seth so like you don't
know
dude it's like doesn't involve you to a
point where it's such a serious
accusation that it needs to be addressed
everybody makes mistakes i am not an
angel i have definitely made mistakes
myself
that he said that it's such a serious
allegation it should be addressed
that's exactly what everyone is asking
for that it should be addressed by the
people
not by you [ __ ] not you but that is all
people are asking for
right just address stuff david
and jason and whoever is involved
directly in a situation
right yeah there's a lot of on
unconscious
irony you'll notice make mistakes is to
learn and grow from those mistakes that
being said telling a lie
is a mistake itself and there's been a
lot of that going around
first of all david's a great person
jason's a great person in fact they're
both
fantastic people david doesn't have a
mean bone in his body he's so nice
when someone does something that really
upsets him he gets disappointed
instead of angry he'll be like why'd you
do that
like that's not cool dude okay this part
was so
just so weird to me so weird he starts
by saying these guys can't have done
this because they're great guys
they're really nice to me yeah also
he goes he goes
shredder just got a scent of uh scott's
[ __ ]
he goes uh david doesn't get mad at
people he just gets disappointed
it's like i'm sorry what is he your
[ __ ] grandmother
like how many what what is there to be
mad about so much
he doesn't get mad people i'm just it's
kind of funny that they have so many
unspoken protocols
right he just he's such a great guy he
only gets disappointed at people never
mad
again very cold the thing is that he may
be nice to you
and that doesn't mean anything about how
what he does with other people of course
especially because which is one of the
beautiful people that's again why you
shouldn't really
be involved in this conversation but
what
what does that say about the the power
dynamic where david being disappointed
means anything
yeah it's like i'm just like who [ __ ]
cares
you know what i mean be mad be mad what
does it mean be disappointed he's not
your parent
it's just odd yeah it's just i find that
statement very odd and telling like from
a psychological standpoint
ah i wonder if david's gonna be showing
some disappointment to scotty for this
one
not anger though that's disappointment
jason also is like the sweetest most
caring there for you
anytime you need him personally have you
heard trisha
have you heard like she ended up in a
mental hospital
i'm glad they were nice to you dude like
what the [ __ ]
were you in a relationship with him
it's crazy how he can miss the point
once again
i truly think that in the age of me too
and everybody's so woke about issues
like this
the very fact that it's a male victim
just makes everybody forget about
everything they ever learned in the past
10 years about it
because this is just classic victim
dismissal and
you know this kissing prank i guaran
[ __ ] to you
if it was instead of seth happened to
like natalie which is like this girl
that everybody loves
it was where jason was putting his
tongue down her throat and touching her
thigh in her back
that this guy would be [ __ ] this guy
would be
outraged that jason would be go to jail
you know what i mean like absol
obviously would be pure outrage if the
if the genders were reversed
i would like to think that but i
honestly
don't even know i think it would be
people get away with a lot of [ __ ] um
because it okay i'm not going to make
assumptions see them being attacked like
this is just like
it's ridiculous if you watch david's
vlogs you've seen people come and go
from them
from time to time and it's always that
person grew apart their career path
changed they didn't want to be in the
videos anymore and and sometimes it's
because they did something that wasn't
cool
and it's like all right we're going to
distance ourselves from you now and
that's it i think that right now
how many how many people are you guys
inviting to your circle that are
being need to be cut out yeah you know
what i mean
sometimes people join the vlog and
either their careers go [ __ ]
uh sideways or we have to cut ties with
them
okay sounds healthy that is fueled by a
lot of unsubstantiated gossip and lies
and that sucks you gotta be careful with
what you're putting out on the internet
and the claims that you're making
without
verifying them if you're telling a lie
and it snowballs it becomes something
that you cannot take back you can't
retract it and then you just end up
damaging
people's lives for no reason and
probably damaging your own life as well
so i would just like to say
don't call it sharing your truth if
you're sharing a lie
bro that is like the most ironic
statement ever yeah
don't call it it's not your truth to
speak on this has nothing to do with you
and he continues to call it a lie and
you'll see as we go through that there's
no [ __ ] evidence
that he shows that seth lied about
anything
nothing seth lied about nothing um
he says what do you say he he directly
uh addresses me towards the back but i'm
gonna go back right because
well here he says that just don't spread
a lie that will snowball and ruin
people's life right that i think is
directed to you
based on the ending judging people's
lives for no reason and
probably damaging your own life as well
so again well
i'll respond to him i guess when he
mentions me at the end but it's like
this is seth telling his story directly
he says do your research
i don't know what more research i can do
other than having the account of the
person it happened to
you know i mean like i mean that's
that's a first-hand account
bro that's like as solid as it gets i
mean what do you want from me
exactly apparently and then they always
he said you should have reached out to
david
i'm sure david would respond to me about
this just like he's been ignoring seth
for two years
just like philip defranco said he
reached out to him and didn't get
comment
i love this expectation that i need to
reach out to everybody
and just wait forever for them to give
me a response like i owe them that it's
not like we have a relationship with
david we don't also this isn't 60
minutes bro like i mean
but like you he wouldn't have responded
to me he doesn't respond to anybody you
literally
if he wanted to say anything he's got
the biggest platform in the world
just saying what do you have to say he
started the video by saying that we
don't respond to this [ __ ] but i should
have reached out to dave yeah
okay dude
so i would just like to say don't call
it sharing your truth if you're sharing
a lie
yeah that's like the most [ __ ] up
thing that is just seriously such
so stupid i mean it's so
it's so missing the point i can't
believe that he actually said that
that's what that's exactly what victim
shaming is don't share your truth if the
truth is a lie who are you to determine
that bro
look at that smug face on him right now
he's like bro i just died i just
i just did something to you i just did
something to you
i cannot his smirk it's not true what
was that
sound bites are coming in
i cannot his smirk i didn't even hear
his smirk
oh i accused david and jason of sexual
assault for a kissing prank that was
done in 2017 which is so [ __ ] up
because
he was part of the videos he knows what
we do and then after the prank was
finished
david asked him too long after that i
had an idea to pull the prank on him
again so i thought it would be fun
i think we'll be all right get you to
make out with chase i'm very confused by
that because how the hell can you be so
confident to tell me that i
have to consent to something that i'm
not gonna know that i'm gonna do
david films hours and hours of footage
and crams them into four minutes
okay so again again
again i have to say he accused me of not
doing research
but he clearly didn't even watch our
interview because we [ __ ] addressed
this
but also he he brushed so fast over the
first
incident he is he's mentioning there was
a kiss impression yeah and then he goes
into talking about the second time
right right away the the point the big
point here scott
is that the first one there was no
consent and that was the reason the
first one was the trauma
you know and so um i don't know how you
miss that but then he goes on to say oh
well he
filmed so his evidence that that was
okay is that well he filmed him the
second time
and what he said clearly is not giving
consent by the way
and also as david's as seth said in the
interview
if you watch it which you clearly didn't
and you're conf you're criticizing me
for not doing research
is seth said that he never gave consent
and he told him not to do it
and all david cut in was this clip of
him saying how can i give you consent if
i don't know what you're going to do
which is literally not consent
he also explained something that you
don't seem to understand is just
the pressure in this situations and as a
victim
you may be going along with it because
you're on camera
you're trying to look cool you're trying
to be cool with the fans
so the fact that it kind of went along
with the second one or whatever that
doesn't mean that it wasn't a traumatic
experience or that he has now trauma
with himself
after the fact yeah that's that's like
one of the
classic victim shaming let's say
fallacies there's like there's a bunch
of victim-shaming fallacies and he hits
on all of them one of them is like why
did
why didn't he why did it take so long to
come forward
because you know it's like i it's the
fact that i even have to explain this
stuff is ridiculous because i know he
knows this
if it was a girl he would know this why
did it take so long for her to come
forward
a lot of victims often don't realize
that they've been traumatized until
years later because it takes time to
figure things out in your mind okay why
didn't she leave sooner
i'm just i'm using it in terms you
understand that's what i'm doing from
the female perspective because so you
understand it scotty
why didn't she leave sooner a lot of
times victim abuser relationships are
really complicated
and the victim often wants to please the
abuser to be accepted by them
right it's a complicated relationship he
says later
in the video if it's so serious why
didn't he go to the police again why
didn't you go to the police another one
i mean that's such a complicated
question to ask why didn't it take so
long to figure this out to even think oh
there was a crime
you know also with seth specifically
there is so much
the baggage with where he comes from and
i mean do we really need to go there
it's like yeah
it may not be that easy for him to go to
the police something you don't
understand
i'm all i'm saying this now he hasn't
said it yet but he will because he
literally hits
every single fallacy victim shaming
fallacy
the the one he said in the beginning he
was nice to me
okay and it doesn't mean that he did
anything bad to anyone else
and then he goes on to try to
assassinate his character calls him a
clout
chaser uh
uh exit yeah we'll get into it i'm
getting ahead of myself
but like he's so missing the point bro
for the videos he knows what we do and
then you know the prank is
finished david asks how is that what you
do
that's not what you do you didn't get
pranked like that show me where you had
jason
uh stick his tongue down your throat and
grab your ass and also have david admit
on camera on his podcast which scotty
never addresses
that it was racially motivated because
he knew he was from compton
bro too long after that i had an idea to
pull the prank on him again so i thought
it would be fun to play your music
permission to try to prank you again and
get you to make out with jason i'm very
confused by that because how's that
so confident to tell me that i have to
consent to something that
i'm not gonna know that i'm gonna do
david films
wow did you hear consent did you hear
consent well i think he's alluding to
the fact that he cut it out
probably or something because he has to
cut down the food no that was in the
video we talked about it we showed it
when we interviewed seth i said what is
this
he's basically calling seth a liar i
know but he didn't nobody cut that out
we that was in the original
video no he's saying david has to cut
out his footage because he shoots for so
much but the video is only 40 minutes
yeah but seth explained that he said he
never gave him consent
which is evidenced by the fact that he
never showed him saying it's
still beside the point because he's not
addressing the first time he did not
consent to the first time
or the second time though or the second
time
he didn't consent to the second time he
failed to prove that he consented to the
second
he doesn't show footage of showing
otherwise i don't know
he failed to show that and seth already
explained this
which he clearly didn't see hours and
hours of footage and crams them into
four minutes and 20 seconds for his
vlogs so this clip was cut
short to not actually show seth giving
his consent but showing that
so where's asking for this when i first
watched it i was like okay so i was like
okay
i was like good how's that good if you
if you're showing saying yes it's fine
then include it you never [ __ ] showed
it you literally never showed it and i
was like what the hell is this sorry ass
video
you think david would go and film this
bit
if seth had said no uh no proven
what am i supposed to just trust you
like what the [ __ ] you what kind of
point are you trying to make
do you really think his defenses do you
really think david would do that
he is such a nice guy okay bro
you think he bleaches his tips do you
think that's his natural hair color i'm
just
curious because i like his hair yeah
because i'm in the market now for
for tip advice i think that's natural
really yes
oh a b says he's a redhead naturally
wait is he redhead no
what i mean is that kind of red hair
that looks right i guess
maybe he's the expert on all this here
he's typing
go ahead abe you can tell me about
history i was giving a shot of hair tips
no i was trying to find a picture of him
with his natural hair color but yeah
oh that's right that's not his natural
hair huh huh but if he's cool you know
he's not like
you know i wonder you think he'll put me
in touch with a stylist
after this video maybe not bro you
literally just sent me a jfif
file like what the [ __ ] is this what am
i like
what are you sending me i'm trying to
run a show not download like zip
converter
sent me a file of a jfif file it says it
just shows like an empty file like it
doesn't know how to open it
i don't know why i say all right let's
move on
anyway nice hair scotty in hell this is
from
we got the okay this isn't boring it
really isn't
here's his natural hair you're right
it's not important it's not
here let's move on
a period of time when david was always
at my house editing and i
very vividly remember when he was
editing that clip there was a clip
in there of seth agreeing and giving his
permission
to film this bit again he was like
there's no way you're going to get it on
me again there's no way you're going to
get me again not yet so go ahead go for
it
okay okay okay where's the clip bro
i mean even if that existed yeah exactly
it doesn't
address the first time i still don't
think that it would change my mind that
much
about anything it's just it's just more
of a comment about how like
yeah poorly conceived this video was
yeah
but you're right because he fails to
adjust the first time by the way
and the podcast clip which i think he
must not have seen either while accusing
me of not doing my research
in which david says i'll sh i'll show it
again for to
because some people may not have seen it
in fact let me just
open it so scotty if you're watching
this
i do think that this is a very important
clip which you did not mention
which is from the podcast ever fake it
was so
perfect and i feel so bad and it's just
it's it's awful
because poor guy had to go through that
and his friends are probably going to
chew him out for that for the next like
three five years of his life well as
seth tells it the uh homosexuality is
not so accepted in his where he comes
from
that's from compton dudes kissing dudes
is not so excited that's from compton so
it's like the perfect
like these straight dudes kissing
literally the perfect setup like
a guy from compton and i made a makeout
with another older man
it's good for seth it gets him some air
time
yo scotty you didn't respond to that
part dude
like why didn't you respond to that if
you're all about research and putting
out the truth
that seems really [ __ ] up and you know
something that stands out to me again is
when i interviewed seth it st it struck
out to me how they specifically targeted
him
because he was minding his own business
he just got back from the airport he was
driving home
and they specifically call him and say
come over like this prank was for
seth they specifically targeted seth
and seth said i think it's because it
was racially motivated and i was like
well that'd be messed up if it's true
but like how can i know but this clip
came out and i was like oh my god he was
right it was definitely racially
motivated
so scotty i mean where you at bro on the
facts
on the uh research you know
wake up scotty wake up
wake up scotty
this is after so now he shows a clip of
after and again this is all public [ __ ]
right like we've talked about all this
this is after the second prank the beef
jerky prank
again so go ahead go for it you're the
best you're the [ __ ] bestie
this [ __ ] told me he's in shock
by the way
if you've listened seth talk about it
excuse me he was in shock because he
thought he was getting this big
commercial deal he told his family he
was depending on the money
he pulled the [ __ ] rug out from under
him it was all fake
and he left him his ass empty-handed too
which he didn't mention
about how in the commercial deal he was
meant to get 2 500 bucks
and um and then david wasn't gonna pay
him
he was like dude i need that money like
i bet and
it's just the fact that he's even
showing this clip
just shows how he doesn't know anything
about like
victim again because seth explained he's
like it was either throw hands or be
cool about it yeah he's on camera he's
put on the spot
this is like it doesn't mean anything
no it's insane it's really
sad because it seems like as people say
scotty is an otherwise really nice guy
so it's just weird to see a guy miss the
point so much i think it's more of a
testament to
the cultish vlog squatty and david
definitely
put him up to this even if it was a
subconscious by sending him
that extra evidence you get which you
guys will see and being like yo like you
know what i mean like he knew he was
gonna make this video he [ __ ] let him
he threw his ass to the walls bro
respect the [ __ ] man that keeps his
word you can tell by his reaction at the
end of the video that he was pranked it
was all in good fun and he gave
permission beforehand he gave david
no no what you're saying is not first of
all
him reacting like that is not proof he
gave permission no and how what does
that mean
what does that even mean and also he's
in shock clear i mean stop props
on getting him with that prank a second
time some of david's vlogs happen just
like in real time you know like and
and something will happen and he
captures it on film but most of these
things are preconceived and everyone
talks about like what bit is going to be
filmed so a lot of the things that seth
was in were his ideas not saying that
was this one was this one preconceived
did seth
no obviously not based on the way david
talked about it on his podcast
and what seth's first account so what is
your point here
these kissing pranks were his ideas but
he did give consent to them and he
partook in them you have not protected
several bits after and before the next
ones and
was totally fine with it like i had
never heard a word from him about being
uncomfortable
not only to force anyone to do anything
this is so sad this is like a
this is like a tutorial on how to victim
shame so you
you never heard him say he's
uncomfortable so therefore it must be a
lie
did you hear him say on our podcast that
he was uncomfortable do victims of abuse
just walk around talking about how about
how uncomfortable they are
yeah you know he even said in his
interview which again you didn't watch
about how it took him a while to
internalize it and understand
the dynamic of the group and how it was
affecting him and how he's like the butt
of all these racist jokes again that you
don't
acknowledge there's a clip somewhere
upset
pranking jason okay so now
one action now we move on to the um
victim
dragons that the character assassination
portion of this video
okay seth did a prank where he put his
ass in jason's face
so it excuses what happened to him sorry
bro i'm not [ __ ] on board with this
argument at all
and what's your point of bringing this
up exactly
well he put a he's put his ass in
jason's face once so that
totally excuses be being assaulted yeah
like sexy
this is like everybody's [ __ ] around
with each other here we're all friends
and like sorry about a song
david looked through his text messages
and found one of seth's numbers asking
him
to do the kissing prank a third time
seth literally requested to do it so
this is important this is where you know
david's involved and this is probably
how david got his ass to make the video
and it's a this is interesting because
it's an insight to how really david
feels about this situation yeah
this is david's response you know
so here he goes a third time guys this
is a text from seth from about two years
ago he goes yo bro i was thinking about
it i'm down for another kissing sketch
i said ha ha what do you mean he goes
low i don't really care as long as you
clout me up
i'm not gay just don't care and then he
sends me this
i mean yeah i mean i don't know i mean
it's not really a big deal
it means the same [ __ ] just i don't know
more open-minded i don't know if seth
completely freaked out again he
the fact that he says in that that he's
more open-minded now
means that he was pissed but he was not
pissed off about
the previous two times but as i as i
kind of said it's like
the fact that seth asked to do it a
third time
does not negate anything that happened
before
i mean it doesn't mean that he can
still feel the way he feels now that
that is
what happens to victims in in a abusive
situations you can go back and want it
again
and that doesn't mean that two years
later you're gonna realize
or ten years later you're gonna realize
that you were in a really [ __ ] up
situation you were being used and abused
and you crave their approval you crave
their attention you crave their
um their pro yeah so so that that's how
i see this it's just
missing the point and you're pointing it
as like the big slam dunk
like hey look he wanted it a third time
no one knew that why'd she go back
that's like the white shoe go back then
fallacy yeah he wants the approval of
david he wants the approval of the vlog
squad it's this really powerful potent
thing right and it's it's so val and so
much comes with it so much good things
come with it
and then he thinks to himself maybe i
made a mistake maybe
i am overreacting maybe i should be cool
with them again and be
in with them again maybe it's good for
my career what am i doing why am i
withdrawing i want to
i want to please them i need this
attention for my career yeah all these
stuff
so he says you know what i'm gonna maybe
i should do it again you know
get him cool with them it'll be another
video i know i got [ __ ] over the last
few times but this time i'll make sure i
don't get [ __ ] over clout me
up and he probably feels ashamed about
even going back and asking for that
third time
right it's not really anything to um
it's not brag about it's not
i'm sure he's very ashamed of that but
that doesn't mean anything about the
accusation
right and it's often very complicated
like this and which is a reason why
victims don't come forward
yeah because there's a bun there's
people be like oh well this and this and
this and this
i was like okay your feelings are valid
it's like you're carrying a lot of
guilt and shame remember what he said in
the beginning
don't tell me your truth if it's a lot
yeah
a break time i know it's kind of though
let's not do it now okay yeah i'm not
gonna do a break now peace and love
forgot about that or if he just hoped
that david would never find it the way
that he hoped that
david had a new computer and didn't have
the extra four hours of footage no i
don't
okay wait let me go back [ __ ] dumbass
i don't think he forgot about it dude
yeah i'm sure he didn't
i don't know more open-minded i don't
know if seth completely forgot about
that or if he just hoped that david
would never find it the way that he
hoped that
david had a new computer and didn't have
the extra four hours of footage that
surrounded the four minute and twenty
vlog
so what is he referring to because i
haven't seen that footage
he's just saying he doesn't have the
phone
how convenient yeah he's saying though
that
seth is lying so but that's interesting
because it implies that they were
looking for it
together right right
we got to take this [ __ ] seth guy out
instead of just apologizing to him
yeah because that would have still been
only consent for the second time but
what about the first time
you're still not addressing the racially
motivated first
not addressing it yeah
wake up scotty included the
bit of him consenting to the prank but
what you're doing is [ __ ] up seth also
you posted revenge porn of our friend
aaron do you know how that's affected
her
he posted revenge porn which is actually
it's 100
illegal it's totally immoral and
so so [ __ ] up did you get her consent
i don't mean to sound aggressive okay so
this is something that gets brought up a
lot by people who are
i guess trying to defend david now again
this is further
character assassination and what
aboutism whatever seth has done
has whatever he seth did in that
situation has literally nothing to do
with this
and he's trying to change the
conversation he's trying to assassinate
his character
legitimize him that being said it is
something that comes up a lot
and although i'm not here to defend seth
in any way i looked into it and i just
because i really wanted to understand i
mean it sounds like
what happened so there's this girl i'm
just going
i'm not defending seth i'm just
explaining what happened because it took
me a minute to understand the situation
so there's this girl seth who used to
and correct me if i'm wrong at any point
maybe because i know you're
familiar with all the timeline there's
this
uh girl aaron who was a part of the vlog
squad her ex-boyfriend
there's a clip of her using a racial
slur the n-word
but she was naked in that clip um
a private a private clip it wasn't
public it was a private clip that her
ex-boyfriend took of her or something
like that
and he threatened i guess she she said
in her video that he was blackmailing
her to put it out
sounded horrible i mean horrible
situation the ex-boyfriend yeah
i mean i felt really the ex-boyfriend
the ex-boyfriend was threatening her and
blackmailing her it was a horrible
situation i felt really bad for him he's
absolutely terrible and so apparently
he does release it or she said that he
wanted money or something and
some guy by the way jesus yeah and she
said she's not going to pay him so
he put it out there of her naked saying
the n-word
okay and so that's out there
by her ex-boyfriend and then seth
makes this video in response to
the vlog squad he called it uh
fake activism because he felt like these
guys do have signs of racism in amongst
them
and but they were doing all this like
black lives matter stuff and so he's
like oh this is fake activism
so he made a video about their fake
activism and in that video was a very
was very briefly aaron saying the n-word
but just to say he did he didn't even
blur he
totally blacked out the bottom part and
it was just her head saying it
so when i watched that video back i
didn't i had no idea that she was naked
or anything but
um so seth included that video in his
compilation very briefly um
and uh that's basically what happened
now should have should seth have
included that that clip in his
compilation
no it was messed up because it was a
private clip
it was calling attention to it
and um i definitely don't think that
seth should have included that clip and
i understand her being like i i just
don't want people
you know it's like so traumatic it's
something that's so dramatic for her the
whole situation so
seth should not have included that in
his clip but
but uh so so no i'm not i'm i'm not
gonna defend seth on that situation but
i do think it's important to understand
what actually happened because
to just put be like oh he shared revenge
p word yeah vast oversimplification of
what happened
i kept hearing that because that's
something a lot of people would bring up
now
and um i had imagined something like
well revenge porn is is true listen i'm
not here to defend i'm not here to
defend
him in any way but that's what happened
it was messed up he shouldn't have done
that
yeah it's got nothing to do with this
that's my point it's got literally
nothing to do with this
i mean you're trying to change the topic
and you're trying to assassinate his
character
okay and it's got nothing to do with
this so why are you bringing it up
exactly that's it that's all i want to
say about that you know what i mean
yeah i'm trying to be very logical here
but
what you're doing and what you've done
is so [ __ ] up and the lies that you're
telling are ruining other people's lives
and i know that you spoke to david a
couple years ago in private and told me
he felt uncomfortable about the video
and so he took the video down
and i totally understand unlisted
by the way he's admitting here that last
year it took place
that he told him he's not comfortable
with it anymore so how is he saying in
the first part
yeah how is he saying in the first part
like i never knew anything about it
it's like you're saying that a few years
ago or last year
he tol asked david to take the videos
down which seth said once again in the
interview that you didn't watch
that he didn't even private them he
unlisted them which seth
didn't appreciate because i guess people
were still able to find it or
also if it's in a playlist you can still
watch it right unlisted you can watch it
if you have the link if it's in a place
exactly
also you ignore the part where seth said
he started he wanted to offer
money to leave it up and seth knew at
that moment that you guys were not his
friends
you ignored that part scotty which by
the way if he's a clown chaser he would
just take the money but he didn't he
said please remove it
which david didn't even do dude so like
you're totally
misrepresenting the truth which which is
what you're accusing me of
what the f oops was that you yeah but i
don't think it matters
you'll just finally kick the soundboard
[Laughter]
off
[Laughter]
about the video and so he took the video
down and
i totally understand feelings of regret
and feeling uncomfortable about
something that you've done in the past
but you can't blame your
uncomfortableness or your regret for
your actions
when you were it wasn't his actions bro
the first two the first one for sure
like we can't even debate
i don't think it's your place to be here
and say what he can or can't feel right
now
it's just not yeah you just haven't been
through the situation and you just don't
understand it clearly you don't
understand but what your his feelings is
that david is such a nice guy
he doesn't have a bad bone in his body
he doesn't get mad at people just
disappointed
listen seth i'm disappointed and
therefore i will not pay you
yeah what i owe you yeah just
disappointed hey do you think that
scotty's going to get a disappointing
talking to you after this video
you put out um
probably scotty i'm not mad i'm just
why did you do that man that's how he
says he talks why did you do that man
apart you partook in it you were
interested in it you wanted to do it you
wanted to be clouded up
and i could totally see you being
uncomfortable about that bit now in
hindsight
so why can't your master aka david
just come in and say something just you
know
when sorry seems to be the hardest word
yeah either
singing song just come out and say sorry
just say you know seth you know that was
wasn't cool
like and let's start there what do i
gotta do to make you love
me i'm gonna get claimed for singing
that too perfectly
what have i gotta do to make you care
why'd you have to bring that up it's
been playing in my head
oh what do i say when lightning strikes
me when sorry seems to be
the hardest word oh
there it is
okay i can do this all day folks
it's a sad situation
all right let's move on i'll join
everybody i know that you were just
filming videos for david's channel and
probably hoping that it built up your
social media platform
and you built a career out of it and i
don't think that that worked and i think
you got bitter about it and after a
couple years
something out of this i was embarrassed
in that prank and i want something out
of it so i'm going to
go after them okay what you're doing
here right now
is so bad it's so you are that is so
[ __ ] up bro that you're even putting
that out there yeah
your career failed so you were looking
for some way to get something out of
this
you were bitter and now you're lying
because it didn't work out for you
this is totally you speculating right
now so why put that out there
he's so diluted man he's got i don't
know what is going on this guy's brain
but like
i can't imagine even putting that out
there like they must they must be having
these internal conversations among
themselves i do
just getting all worked up you know i do
think that this
is exactly what they're all thinking
this is definitely
for sure everyone's words in that group
this is what they're saying
for sure that's why it's that's like
actually what an echo chamber is is
they're in this group chat
everyone's super pissed they're totally
convinced that what they're saying is
right
and so he comes out here being like i've
got the answers but then
everyone's like this ain't it yeah cause
we're not in that echo chamber
where daddy david is [ __ ] daddy dom
david
daddy dumb david will you change my
diaper
daddy daddy maddie
so [ __ ] up okay what about trisha then
she's really successful what's her
excuse
yeah why you shouldn't i mean whatever
it's like it's stupid okay what about
this bird what about big nip what about
treasure what about that don't you think
there's
just like maybe one or two too many
people coming out
with accusations to write off as just
bitter maybe there's something within
your guys's organization
that's rotten that's causing all these
people to come out and say they
weren't comfortable with happened there
at least maybe your policy of just
ignoring
doesn't work well how about some real
introspection instead of like
you know like this clearly
is the thought of people who are not
introspective in the least bit
and are just totally not taking any
criticism
common tendency for people to go and say
that they're not in the videos anymore
because
they were uncomfortable about doing a
bit how then
you were just never hit up again which
is false
in seth's interview with age three he
talked about the situation in one way
and in his other interviews earlier he
talked about the situation in a
completely
different way at the end of the day i
would have laughed daddy if it was
someone else you know what i'm saying
it's like i'm
a person if i feel like i would laugh at
something like don't
put don't dish anything out he's part of
the gang he's trying to be cool
dude when was this and when was our
interview like you don't
have any space in your mind actually he
does that's what's so odd because he
goes oh now you realize that it was
embarrassing
but then you did it it's like yeah
that's how it works bro
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm gonna call my mom and
see what my mom thinks about this
and i call my mom and she just started
busting up laughing like if my mom
let me read the title this is from david
dobrik's apparently
subreddit seth recently had these videos
deleted off youtube the first was up in
2017
long time ago four years ago yeah right
when it happened
until yesterday the second will probably
be gone tomorrow
we'll probably okay and the second one
seth talks about the prank his busyness
and his thoughts on race and the n-word
it's not like you're saying today
in in this this is 2017. in this current
headspace of seth
he said one thing on this podcast and
another thing on another podcast
that would be interesting but this was a
this conversation wouldn't even take
place everybody knows these things it's
only for men where we don't get this
we people like peop a guy like scotty
like he strikes me as a guy who's very
sensitive
and attuned and like pro women's rights
and me too and all that you know what i
mean like he just
i don't know him personally but i feel
like he gets these concepts
he understands these issues
laughing her ass off everyone else is
i think the magnitude of the lies you've
been spreading are unforgivable and you
should
face repercussions i was there okay so
again this
is as close to a threat for legal action
as you can get because
he's working directly with david
so he knows something about what david's
up to
so when he's saying you should face
repercussion it's clearly something that
they've talked about
now let me also say on the legal merit
that's just so patently absurd
too if anyone has the cause for legal
repercussion it's
david you know what i mean yes seth has
a case he has a real case
you know but like again you're you're
based you're indirectly threatening seth
or saying that the threat of a lawsuit
is out there and it should exist and it
might exist because i talk to david and
he sends me clips
victim scaring
creating these moments and bits with
also once again reminder
investor in dyspo
investor in dyspo
exactly threatening a lawsuit against
seth
so again bro like you really should have
kept your mouth shut on this
and you were here creating the moments
and bits that you were in
with everybody a lot of things were your
ideas
and i don't know how you could lie about
it i mean a lot of things was just like
they just can't stop
those weren't even david says those
weren't his ideas
there's literal proof of you being so
down for doing these bits
and now you're backtracking and saying i
was so uncomfortable but i took the high
road and just like played it off like i
wasn't
you asked to do it a third time and in
retaliation for
this years later you post our friend's
naked body on the internet it's revenge
point
he didn't post okay so once again dude
he did not post her naked body that's a
[ __ ] defamatory lie
he did not post her naked or maybe i'm
missing something
maybe i'm missing and it sounds like
everyone looked into it i mean i hope
i'm not missing something speaking out
of turn but from what i can tell
is that he only he used in this video
and it wasn't it was cropped all the way
out
there was no nakedness there was no even
hint of nakedness
so he should not have used that clip
which was very private and draw
draw attention to it but to say he
posted the naked v
the naked image of your friend is really
[ __ ] up to say
in my opinion after looking over the
facts i hope i'm not wrong
i might be speaking an attorney he may
have tweeted it or something so i don't
know but we looked really hard into this
to try to make sure we were right on
this
as far as i can tell he didn't people in
the chat saying yes he did
he did see i don't know what what's true
and what other people are saying he did
not so
i blurred it the whole vlog squad have
been putting forward this thing that
he's
put posted naked pictures of her and so
i think there's a lot of people that
think that's true but as far as
i could tell based on all the research
we did which was it might be
that he didn't blur it at first or
didn't crop it at first and then he did
it after
on the internet or on in the video yeah
there's
somebody was saying he posted it
uncensored at first
so it's first [ __ ] yeah that is [ __ ]
up
yeah but i don't know what's the truth
unfortunately
because i mean everybody's saying he did
but i mean there's
i haven't seen evidence and you know
there's a lot of misinformation about
about it well it is [ __ ] up but again
yeah i'm not i'm not here to
so so maybe he's right maybe i'm
speaking at a turn and i'm definitely
not here to defend seth on that point
like let me make that very clear like
just because seth has done something
[ __ ] up doesn't mean that he can't be
a victim you know what i mean
which apparently is his point which is a
really bad point
it's like just if you've made you know
again i i don't know what's the truth on
that
i have never found that tweet in my
research of him sharing
that if someone has it i'm just curious
to know what's the truth because
if they're putting that out there and
it's not true that's really twisted in
my opinion
but if it's true i then then it's super
[ __ ] that he did that you know
i mean for sure
i mean the thing is that we look wait
but again it's not that's not what we're
even talking we're not
saying that seth is a saint or anything
really
it's well it's just a whole separate
conversation this is like a separate
issue
yeah really so i shouldn't even i that's
why i feel like i shouldn't even speak
on the topic
it's just that he brings it up and a lot
of people bring it up and so i wanted to
explain it as best as i could
but i'm not i don't know i don't want it
to seem like we're ignoring it either
because
we are aware of this situation just as
much as we can we weren't following the
situation when things happen
so one thing for sure is that it's it's
hard to for us
now to understand what the timeline was
back then if anybody had yeah
i don't know you guys are looking at
chat and stuff so if you see any like
actual evidence i'm really curious
i'm googling around right now and the
only
thread i can find about it on twitter um
is him saying the video was not
monetized nor was there nudity in the
video but thank you for your
input right i've read that she is
saying why would you put that clip out
of me and that was his response
so i don't know i mean i don't know
there may have been
so what i'm suspecting happened is there
was a
version of the video that we've all seen
where the nudity was just blurred
and then he got backlash for it and he
deleted it and re-uploaded it with fil
with it fully cropped
i think that that's how this play really
i i think so
just based off i mean i'm inferring from
an old twitter
thread so because obviously the original
video was gone if it ever
was up so well who knows it's not my
area yeah i i don't know
it seems like again it is still not
defending that anyways you should have
done that that's the point yeah it is
still beside the point though of
it's not the it's not what we're here to
talk about and i think that's very
important to say is that he's trying to
change the topic yeah
you know
and for this years later you post our
friend's naked body on the internet it's
revenge point it's a little
you're saying he blurred it but well
whatever again it doesn't matter
it's [ __ ] up you suck i can only speak
on what i know about and i know that
seth and big nick have both been on h3's
podcast and you
are part of the reason that these
livestreams snowballs so here we go
oh you know when someone mentioned my
name i i'm up for it
oh boy this is the moment we've been
waiting for
play that champ music for me get the war
horn going
no we're over those serious parts
that's first of all before he mentions
my name before anything goes down hit me
with another
foghorn wikifeed scotty
sire you know what time it is foot
soldiers
a call to arms or call defeat oh dude
he's already gotten wrecked
wait did the footstool just already
visit his page no
the food soldiers have already laid bare
a desecration upon scotty cyrus wiki
feet
there shall be no survivors
oh scotty's kind of into the whole
wikifeed thing look at these shots bro
he's right here
this is whoa how dare you
what the [ __ ] scotty you were trying to
get that high rating bro
like that
wow dude soldiers have already been here
that's crazy
y'all are next level i've been saying
the messages throughout this whole thing
tank is scoring so oh god hitch forks
are out ready
av says it was a 4.6 before the show
started oh no
boy oh that's rough scotty
you [ __ ] i want to smell feet oh is
that so ela
never said she never said that well i
happen to be number one on wiki feed so
if there's any footage you should be
smelling it's mine
you should be so honored this
years later you post all right scotty
what do you have to say about me
naked body on the internet it's revenge
point it's legal it's [ __ ] up
you suck i can only speak on what i know
about and i know that seth and big nick
have both been on h3's podcast and you
are
part of the reason that these lies have
snowballed and gotten so big because
you're jesus
do you think the reason this snowballed
and got so big is because david
never responds and he sends you out to
[ __ ] respond do you think part of the
reason why this is snowball got so big
is because david literally doesn't
[ __ ]
answer seth's text like says said in the
interview if he would have just answered
his text a few days before he came on
the show he wouldn't even come on the
show and [ __ ] talked about it so how
is it my [ __ ] fault
that this has snowballed when david and
jason have literally made no effort to
make peace with these guys nor address
these rumors
publicly so how the [ __ ] is it my fault
for this snowballing
right i'm same i mean same with big nick
like big nick said that david never made
any public kind of
acknowledgement of what happened or how
things ended like
it's just things need to be addressed
not by you
you know come on dude
this is stupid get your head out of your
ass scotty
don't make me go back to your you're
wiki page
dog faced pony soldier ponytail come on
man
spreading the lies without any sort of
verification in fact when they were
i have done dude to say that i have not
verified is so ironic considering your
video
has has omitted so much
information has completely not addressed
the main
thrusts of the accusation and to come
here and say that i have
spread lies which you have made no
effort to even dispel
based on like hearsay and situational
evidence is so
i don't know if he's just dumb or he's
just too angry i don't know
you yourself just did it in this video
spreading your own speculation that seth
is just doing it because his career
didn't succeed and he's just looking to
get something out of the situation right
i mean that's [ __ ] that's a rotten
thing to say bro
all right be cool ethan this is the foot
soldier moment though i can be amped up
during this part
right no i heard i'll play the foghorn
play it
quickly now you're living
oh you hear that he loves the call of
battle
when they were talking i watched you
ethan take what they said and say
oh that's so [ __ ] up so they did this
you like you would take their words and
you would make it sound even worse than
what they
shut up dude it's called interviewing
douche it's called asking
follow-up questions you dumb ass it's
also
our opinion i think we're allowed to uh
you
think about it what are we thinking
about you made it sound bad
and that was [ __ ] up
yeah you made it sound bad because you
think it's bad right
i do think it's bad okay but it's called
follow-up questions
bria
would you want me to just make it sound
nice oh this probably will not date
that's probably not what david meant
i did not have consent are you sure you
didn't have consent because i mean david
is a really nice guy and he would not do
that to anyone
that's scotty's version of how that
interview should have gone listen david
as i know he's never mad at people just
disappointed
that's not something he would ever do no
no
what he said was that's not something we
would ever do
take their words and you would make it
sound even worse than what they said
but i i think that you should in the
future at least try to verify some of
the information
reach out to the people that you have
again reach out to david like phil
defranco did
who like he like he never got a response
like probably tons of [ __ ] media
people have been reaching out to him
non-stop
he has not made a comment i should have
reached out i should have fact
checked the original source the first
hand account of a victim i should have
fact checked that what are you
saying it doesn't make sense
and now you got a one on wiki feed bro
look what you've done to yourself
i'm not a one i don't know let's check
maybe a 1.2
i don't know scotty
let's go back scotty sire
here i got to keep the pa i got to keep
his wiki page open as we
go through this he's down to a 3.2 yeah
he's still pretty good do you think he's
got nice feet i mean he's jacked he's
like a handsome guy but
the feet shots don't really do it for me
i mean i want to smell the feet
that's a lot don't you think
yeah wait you hesitated you like his
foot
no i don't like okay and my problem is
that i
pretty much don't like any foot oh it's
a lot for you to take in
interesting guess i'm talking about
because the things that are being said
on youtube now and on your
podcast show are things that should be
said in a courtroom if they're true
classic victim shaming why didn't you go
to the police
next
in the statute of limitations probably
passed but maybe not for civil i i don't
know it's complicated
it's complicated also he's embarrassed
he's humiliated he doesn't even you know
what i mean like it took him years to
come to terms with it you just
how are you misunderstanding this bruh
bruh moment dude anyway that's my take
on the subject and i hope that
people who feel the need to make big
false claims realize that if they're
serious enough they will be addressed
and
hopefully you'll get in trouble for it
exactly another legal threat you'll get
in trouble for it
nice bro so
cause it's it's wrong scotty's hot take
ladies and gentlemen scotty's hot take
everybody
so um
okay now we got to do mint mobile and
we'll talk a little bit about other
stuff
so um we will throw to the ad and we'll
be
right back after the year we've all been
through
saving money should be at the top of
everybody's list
so if you're still paying insane amounts
money every month for wireless
what are you doing
switching to mint mobile is the easiest
way to save this year
as the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only
mint mobile lets you maximize your
savings
with plans that start at just 15 dollars
a month
[Applause]
um dan actually is using mint mobile dan
tell us about your experience yes sir uh
it's super simple
i'm gonna send you this little envelope
and inside comes a sim card
you just pop that little puppy it's not
here anymore cause i popped it out but
you pop that puppy into your phone uh do
a little sign up
boom bam took about like 15 minutes
bob's your uncle and uh
it works great and you are cruising
along at just fifteen dollars a month
how's the service dan
that's the quality it's great it's just
like a uh any of the major carriers
wow and your text messages they they go
through just text messages go through
that's like a mom question
it makes telephone calls too and how are
the calls
uh the email the emails arrive safely at
their destination
wow look at that it works great
nobody answers my phone calls but i
don't think that has anything to do with
the service
it might no it doesn't i mean it doesn't
sorry it does it that's you
for people looking for extra savings
this year mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month by
going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail
mint mobile passes significant savings
on to
you all plants come with unlimited talk
and text
plus high-speed data delivered on the
nation's
largest 5g network use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan and keep the
same phone number along with all of your
existing contacts
and if you're not 100 satisfied mobile
has you covered with their 7-day
money-back guarantee
switch to min mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and to get that plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
h3 that's mint mobile.com
h3 cut your wireless bill to just 15
dollars a month at
mintmobile.com h
three
[Music]
welcome back everybody you know death
noodles just put out a really
interesting uh
again this literally has no bearing at
all on on anything but it is interesting
again
to just show how scotty is
misrepresenting the evidence
so because he shows this clip of seth
like putting his ass in jason's face as
like evidence that oh look he does it
too
but so people dug it up and apparently
this is a prank that jason was doing to
a lot of people
and this was like a retaliation prank so
it's not like but whatever it doesn't
even matter honestly it doesn't matter
oh i did want to read seth's statement
that he sent me
again he was going to come on originally
but he well here i'll just read a
statement
he said and of course he said he this
was meant for me to read on the air
um he said hey ethan i want you to know
i dearly appreciate you covering my
story unfortunately i can no longer
speak about this incident
i will still answer a couple of
questions i know you might have
the audio clip the audio clip and text
that is surfacing the internet is a
manipulation to misrepresent
my trauma and experiences this audio
further concludes i did not consent to
those published videos right
i think he's referring actually don't
know what he's referring to
to the audio bite that um david plays
where he says like i'm not i'm more
open-minded now
he's i think he's saying yeah he says
even in that clip he says i'm more
open-minded now which i guess he's
saying
is evidence that he didn't consent to
the previous two videos
that's what i understand right yeah and
then he says my allegations about
accountability part two that's what the
claim that everyone's making about that
he
shared this nude photo of aaron it was
he used it in this video
accountability part two he said in this
day and ages unfortunate people are
still using pornographic videos to get
revenge
i have not promoted nudity but only
highlighted appear confidently saying
this slanderous derogatory term
the n-word additionally in my
accountability 2 video i reposted
other public clips of my peers as a tool
to show people what behaviors are not
okay
so he claims he never shared
the nude photo so
i don't know i mean he's short footage
from
yeah i mean that's indisputable yeah but
like i do think it's important i do
think it's kind of important distinction
of
if he blurred or totally barred it or if
he shared the nude
you know what i mean like the uncensored
footage
again though it has nothing to do with
the conversation at hand i think that's
important to um to say
whenever we talk about it so um
yeah that's the vlog squad it's a
response
i was really shocked you know when the
first thing i saw
this video it was getting a lot of
support i guess just from the like the
initial responses like support from the
fans
but i knew immediately when i saw it was
like this is this is gonna be so bad
yeah and i immediately felt bad for seth
because like
you know all the trauma he's been
through like why are they trying to bury
him and put him
fur and stomp on him like it's so easy
to just and people the thing
people will admire you for just coming
out and saying all right stop
i shouldn't have done this you know i've
changed we don't do stuff like that
anymore but like i don't know why it's
so hard for them to take accountability
for this
i'm assuming it has to do with the
sensitive situation he's in with like
dyspo and all this stuff
but i do feel like if you would just
issue an apology that wouldn't be such a
big deal necessarily you know i mean
that's all seth ever wanted
but to send his homie out to try to to
take the heat
like bro this isn't even your place and
possibly sue him
like seriously what are you going to sue
seth for exactly
you keep saying he's you didn't show any
evidence he's lying and you're
threatening to sue him
shut the [ __ ] up dude you know david has
such a clean image that he would never
put a video like that
out ever but this is david that's the
thing
like if if you try to imagine the same
video but if
david said it it would be so awful oh
yeah but this is
representing what he wants to say
clearly
i'm speculating but but based on the
fact that
david sent him that with david narrating
it
is proof that he probably saw this video
before it went live
probably all of those guys saw this
video unlisted
and gave their feedback on it and we're
like yeah
this is the this is the perfect response
you know
yeah should i feel bad for scotty i
can't tell
because he seems like an otherwise nice
guy that people like he just kind of
missed the point and got thrown to the
walls by david
yeah i agree with that we're good people
it's like why are you throwing yourself
we wouldn't do this we're good people
why are you throwing yourself in front
of the cannonball for david
you weren't even there this is you
didn't do anything bro so why are we why
are we talking we
you got you bro you got you good
disposable ain't just the name of an app
um since we're on the topic of david
[ __ ] it
this is david another david dobrik
podcast but hey let's do it
uh i keep talking about this puzzle and
i'm sorry to go keep
talking about that [ __ ] i'm not sorry
i'm glad i think this puzzle's
disturbing i don't like it
and i found these really interesting new
developments one i think i talked about
on a previous episode but i'll mention
it real fast because i don't think you
saw it either
yeah so this was posted on the subreddit
when i was just seeing what people
how people were reacting to to
everything
and this was at one point it was just a
really a minor post but i thought it was
really interesting he said i won david
dobrik's 25 cent puzzle but
it's asking for my bank info is it safe
or is it even worth the 25 cents
which is really interesting because that
means that 95 of the people buying this
puzzle are not even going to redeem
their prize
because you have to put in your [ __ ]
bank account and no that's not worth the
effort of getting 25 cents
weird and also most of them are kids and
don't even have bank accounts
so that's part one of david dobrik's not
even giving out prizes for the most part
and then number two which i just saw
like last night or this morning
um is this someone got this email
saying there's only one month left to
complete your puzzle what kind of puzzle
expires let me ask
want this based on the lottery what kind
of puzzle expires
hey there just wanted to let you know
that until march 31st to assemble
you have until march 31st to assemble
your puzzle and collect the winnings
tens of thousands have already won but
the hundred thousand is still out there
no one got a hundred thousand really
you're able to control
who when somebody wins the hundred
thousand that's so interesting to me
it sounds like an unregulated [ __ ]
lottery
when you can actually control who and
when someone wins
after march 31st you'll just have to
wait for the next puzzle we do
how do you know how do you know that
somebody will win before march 31st
that's not fraud
okay what is it i would call that uh
false advertising when you got ja rule
defending you now david that's not a
good sign
dude this is so [ __ ] up they control
who and how they control who and when
that 100 000
goes out i mean this guy's made probably
10 million [ __ ] dollars on that
as well after the third one draw that
conclusion
because what are the odds again i'm
speculating so let me just say that
since dave is already ready to sue me
tens of thousands have already won they
say the hundred thousand's still
out there so how is it that there's a
hundred thousand still out there because
yeah
yeah no one won it yet yet the puzzle
expires on march 31st so how can they
control
if somebody wins the grand prize before
the puzzle expires
they don't so they're so what they're
saying that there's a possibility that
nobody wins 100 000
well i don't think so i don't think
that's what they're saying
i think that's what they're saying well
so what nobody's [ __ ] winning
anything then
everyone's just getting 25 cents and
they're not even redeeming because they
have to connect their [ __ ] bank
account
the whole thing is such a scheme it's so
outrageous guys
just buy a [ __ ] lottery ticket at
least that shit's regulated i swear to
god it's regulated and you don't have to
waste your time putting together a
[ __ ] qr code do you understand
you're putting you're putting together a
qr code that's not even like a
logical puzzle like get a puzzle you
can't pretend like putting together a qr
code is fun
i'm sorry here i'm gonna sell a puzzle
of my
my bare [ __ ] i mean that's pretty
cool
but better than a qr code i don't care
about the qr code puzzle i think that's
whatever but well you're basically
putting together a lottery ticket
yeah i doubt that it's being regulated
of course it's not
what is this this email is proof that
it's not being regulated
you have to give out the prize or
they're controlling
when it's won after the march 31st
you'll just have to wait for the next
puzzle we do
lastly i can't wait to see who wins our
100 000
and also what they've got like marketing
they've got like a marketing strategy
based on the fact that nobody's won it
yet
it sounds to me like i'm speculating
again that they control
when somebody wins this prize
right then you agree what's your take on
i
wake up you don't want to kick no come
on
you know i'm making points here
they didn't invent sweepstakes companies
do this all the time
i agree it's i agree it's shady and
definitely thanks
a sweet thanks a sweepstake is a
[ __ ] way to sell lottery tickets uh
yeah yeah but sweepstakes are also
regulated you're not allowed
and this likely is too and when you're
saying it's not regulated i don't
necessarily but how was there a deadline
and so you're saying there's a chance
they don't give away the grand prize
yeah i mean yeah and that's what i
understand well i don't think the people
who are buying this think that's
possible
i was about to give as an example of the
um how many of these things said
nobody 100 000. i mean what are the
[ __ ] odds on this thing dude it's
crazy
well the 30 bucks for this [ __ ] qr
code
the odds are all listed on their website
in the in the rules of the contest
i looked into it give me that what's the
odds of winning the hundred thousand
oh i want to know right now but can you
imagine like
people so now that said just because
they say all those
i mean there's the famous example is the
the mcdonald's monopoly thing which was
all rigged and everything that was a
sweepstakes too so i mean just because
it's regulated doesn't mean that it's
not rigged but we shouldn't say that
it's regular i'm not saying it's rigged
yeah
i mean we don't know we don't know
anything i'm not saying [ __ ] but i don't
know nothing about nobody
hey i'm like that i'm like that hey i
don't know nothing about nobody
i don't know nothing about nobody i'm
just saying you think that all the fans
buying this [ __ ] puzzle
know that there's a chance a good chance
at this point because march 31st is
coming close and he
he sold more of these puzzles than he's
not you know what i mean like
he's probably sold 90 of the puzzles
he's going to sell before that date hits
and nobody's [ __ ] won that money no
because
people are probably what i understand
from it is that people bought it but
they didn't
complete oh please people [ __ ]
voracious wait who's gonna sit on the
puzzle you think they're not putting
together
yeah i mean who wants to build a phone
you can't keep getting away with it it
says one in a hundred thousand
according to the game there you go yeah
one in a hundred thousand it sells
okay okay
so you have to sell a hundred thousand
puzzles at thirty dollars one
and one hundred thousand one hundred and
fifty one is the exactly i'm gonna
i'm gonna round down one hundred
thousand times thirty
so for every three million dollars he
makes he should be giving away a hundred
thousand dollars
apparently nobody's won which is pretty
incredible
i'm a little skeptical of that
i just want my 25 cents though
i just want a way to redeem my 25 cents
it actually says in the rules total uh
arv
of all i don't know what arab stands for
arv of all prizes to be awarded
is 251 125 so a quarter million
in prizes available whoa whoa whoa whoa
according to the number posted on the
game's rules page only 651 out of 100
000.007
of the prizes available would actually
allow you to gain money by
participating so that means you won more
than wait
yeah that means you won more than 30
bucks if you win 25 cents you you spent
30 bucks on the puzzle you you didn't
you lost money so only 650 out of 100
000 people will actually get more than
thirty dollars
yeah i mean it's it's it's a lottery
like for sure it's a shitty lottery like
i think lotteries even have better odds
than this
i don't know like like you should like a
lot of times if you spend five bucks
online you'll get that five bucks back
at the time right not in the sense of
getting this job this one you're at
point
zero zero seven percent of making your
money there's a chance that
these people are just buying it for the
name of it
and to support their favorite content qr
yeah
sure maybe it's just but it's marketed
at the hundred thousand dollars i mean i
think people are not
david is known for giving [ __ ] away he's
the guy that gives you away
his launch video which if someone pull
up the launch video where he says hey
guys i'm trying to figure out how to
give you guys money people was asking
for your money so now i figured out like
the whole marketing campaign
around this puzzle is him trying to give
away money give me that video
fill that bag up right now watch this
video and then try to tell me that
i mean is that all right somebody get in
the video
somebody's on it
[Music]
maybe you seem pretty calm back there
i mean i'm not supposed to pull up the
videos but i'm still looking
i don't see your hands on the keyboard i
see you look like very casual dude
i'm watching it on if this is the one
you're talking about oh my god okay
let me look david dobrik maybe we
don't have 100
all right you can kill the music
[Music]
one of the most common comments i see is
you guys asking me for money
so i finally figured out a way to get
all of you guys money
i sound like a scam but this isn't scam
listen i made this puzzle it's called a
hundred thousand dollar puzzle by david
dover that's me
so this is how it works you get the
puzzle you start building it it takes a
while so you got to put it together
assuming a lot of people just wouldn't
mean they never even put it together
yeah who wants to build a [ __ ] car so
that's why
you know bro there i understand it's a
puzzle but he
listen he says it's not his he goes i'm
trying to give everybody money it's not
a scam
trust me yeah i know i'm just i'm just
saying
i'm not i'm just saying the whole vibe
the whole marketing thing is hundred
thousand dollar puzzle
i know it's a puzzle no i'm just saying
that my
am i too harsh on this it might be it
might be that people
don't necessarily see it as a big
lottery ticket they're just buying it as
much as the meme
it's a qr puzzle from david you know
you don't even have a cheat sheet to do
it and then when you're done you take
your camera on your phone just like that
and then you scan it because it's a qr
code and look now it'll load your prize
and you're going to 100
win anywhere from 25 cents to a hundred
thousand dollars
and i won 25 cents you win now put in
your bank and photo redemption
but this is it it's [ __ ] sick i'm
gonna leave this link to my bio go get
one for yourself go go one for a friend
for christmas whatever and do me a favor
record your reaction
because you're gonna win anywhere from
25 cents to a hundred thousand dollars
so yeah all right good luck i'll see you
yeah
i mean if okay whatever who cares
yeah i care
obviously
i think a lot of people want them for
tick tocks as well because all the tick
tock videos
they have the puzzle on it usually do
well
they do they're buying that clout oh you
mean the tick tocks
as well got it if somebody makes a tick
tock tick tock is our home
run oh do you have the the crazy mail ad
i got
can you grab that i gotta go get it so i
got in the mail
you know junk mail i'm [ __ ] i'm so
[ __ ] over junk mail you know
but i got this junk mail that i it's
like someone stepped their [ __ ] up
to a level i have never seen before blow
me away
totally and um i
have to share it with you guys um
i think you can be blown away by this
i'm not even quite sure what they're
trying to sell me i think it was a car
ad or something
um here's ela so it arrived in this
envelope
oh i got it it arrived in this envelope
here and i was like
no address right well people know where
we live
so he's bragged in this envelope i was
like what is this it looks like uh
instruction pamphlet or something i
don't know and then it's this
okay you it's this i don't know what
this is
does it say it says bernal bernelli
bernoulli lock okay you guys remember
that better but you guys ready for this
whoa what
[Music]
there's a charging port on the top
that's how you know you made it in life
bro what the [ __ ] yeah you guys know i'm
like i'm made of money or something
this is like a twenty dollar like ad i
mean how much
it's a full color screen there's a
there's a truck and a speaker
there's a whole charging port here
there's a charging port here just in
case i want to watch it again in the
future
yeah i wanted to tear it open and see
what's inside but i wanted to wait to do
it on the screen on here
how does it work every time you open it
it starts over
what are they sending me
the sky oh [ __ ]
okay what it's just an exposed circuit
board
probably a little uh raspberry pi
is this uh dangerous can i can i hurt
myself you should lick it
because if i hurt myself i feel like i
could sue
i feel like this is a poorly okay
it doesn't have enough i can even turn
the sound down
okay look there's some oh and i can skip
forward there's more ads
yeah i think it's a little uh i can
spread five i can fast forward a
computer in there
with some software what is this isn't
this insane
you're living in the future man this
reminds me of blues clues
so anyway there's like a whole circuit
board is there anything we can salvage
in here for the show dan
uh maybe don't touch it
lick that [ __ ] no no
so that's that that's pretty i thought
that was amazing
i was shocked so shout out to uh their
families
all of their families so i don't
yeah we could just watch the whole thing
i mean
so i don't i don't really want to talk
about anything else to be honest with
you guys because
i i don't want the message of the first
part to get lost in the sauce
should we keep i guess we could keep
going
that was my plan
[Music]
[Applause]
okay stop booing
i'll keep going
[Music]
let's [ __ ] goof off it's friday baby
okay
right so all right [ __ ] it let's go baby
thank you dan so we've got
i've got a couple of meme holes we can
fall into
interesting you do you prefer what is
your favorite crazy christian video
or weird suit soaking i don't want to do
the suit soaking
this is not today so epic though i don't
want to do suits
it's like this it's the weirdest fetish
we've found yet
and it's disturbing i don't
it's not really disturbing it's less
disturbing than the cream head
crying yeah because the brain was too
much for me
it's less disturbing than that but it's
it's super [ __ ] weird someone says
you think the car dealership sold our
info it was i'll be no
that's not it there's a reason why i
know that but i can't say
it may be a federal crime i may have
committed a federal crime
what do you mean well it wasn't
addressed to me
oh what yeah oh no you didn't
call the fbi
it was a mistake i apologize to the feds
i didn't realize until after i opened it
please don't lock me up please
let's do crazy christian videos okay
it's not like
it's just weird conspiracy theory kind
of meme whole [ __ ]
and they're all on tech talk of course
your
that doesn't make sense though
crazy go ahead and hit the music see i
knew i should have ended the show
[Laughter]
[Music]
hit him with the 60 minute clock
dan is unplugging the cable he is
fidgeting and futzing
right now it works all right we're good
kill it kill the music
thank you oh you guys want to see
something i've been working on what
you're working on
uh dan are you okay [ __ ] static
electricity
in here is so get some get a rubber mat
or something ringo starr
um peace of mind you guys can i can i
reveal my peace and love all right
they view it right now well it's a work
it's a working program it's a whip
yeah i'm working on a tick tock
where i dress up as ringo and voice this
perfectly
so i want to show you guys what i'm
working with i think i'm making really
good progress
it's hard to hit like the all the
inflections and the pauses perfectly but
let me show you guys what i've got
real quick i'm gonna adjust the
i want you to be side by side with him
so just give me one second okay
you can do that thank you so i've been
trying to learn the peace and love
um perfectly
for the enjoyment of all yeah i do think
ethan needs like maybe another week of
training yeah yeah it's not fully baked
yet
all right i've got you in a big box
okay here we go let's go okay here we go
this is a serious message to everybody
watching the
update right now peace and love peace
and love
i want to tell you that please
after the 20th of october
not send fan mail to any address
that you have nothing will be signed
after the 20th of
october if that's got a signature on the
envelope it's going to be tossed
i'm warning you with peace and love i
have too much to do
no more um thank you no objects to be
signed
nothing uh anyway thank you peace love
peace and love thank you
it still needs a little work but yeah
yeah yeah not bad not bad well
how am i supposed to get better when eli
yells at me every time i practice
so okay yeah ethan will play also super
loud and you know i played as low as i
can
no you don't you don't hear yourself and
use yourself
allowed this is a serious message you do
everybody watching
my update now and also he does it at
midnight
when i'm a little tired peace and love
peace and love
where's the peace and luck so with peace
and love maybe
this is a warning with peace and love
okay let's watch the crazy christian
plans and then
anyway i thought you guys enjoyed that
for now yeah yeah
a year ago with me talking about semen
and and
what's your favorite favorite crazy
christian video
the strange thing that milk comes from
the mammary glands and then et cetera et
cetera
and i said this semen because you know
what they had this thing going back a
year ago when we talk about semen and
and starbucks lattes and they do put it
in there and many people slammed me and
said i should get off of it one guy
told me he wasn't gonna send me any more
offers until i stopped talking about
seba
uh seaman uh talking about it
but at any rate the
what people tend to like milk that's
produced by the mammary glands of them
starbucks has figured it out
why is it that people are it's normal to
drink milk
but i can't drink semen so is
well it's a flip he i don't know what
he's trying to say but it sounds like
he's trying to rationalize some weird
behavior he's got wait
i had zach clipped this because this is
just my favorite part play it again zach
semen is is another kind of milk
right good point well you know semen's
not
really meant to be consumed so i mean
you can consume it with peace and love
but milk is actually meant to be
consumed by babies
why is it that i can't drink buckets of
semen
why is that weird semen
is another kind of sweet man
my fans keep saying stop talking about
semen
but you said this is like a christian
video segment well
yeah he's a pastor oh yeah i i could
whatever wait yeah talking about how
somebody said they were gonna stop
somebody said they were gonna stop
tithing at his church because he won't
stop talking about this and he's like
well
he said you gotta listen to him
carefully he says go ahead stop tithing
i don't care
oh my goodness produced by
the testicle glands of a man it's like
what does this have to do with god
shout out to his family for sure what's
with seaman
seaman is just another milk it's your
favorite crazy
christian baby that's awesome i'll go
for
she's not a christian
get outside
get the hell out of my house in jesus
name i pray
and i've been saying i am a spiritual
warrior because i feel like i'm a
spiritual warrior
like i had to put armor on just to walk
out that house
holy spirit if you believe in jesus you
can stay here
oh
[Music]
i feel bad for her she's having a bad
time
you gotta love it though like a tlc or
something definitely i think it was from
spouses yeah dude that was the craziest
episode so they would
change spouse like switch spouses for
like a certain period of time just to
like see what it's like
and somebody got stuck with this lady
they're like whoa not fair
i rebuke you demons i always wondered
they didn't [ __ ] in that show did they
i don't think that would be
because i was like well what's the point
of changing spouses
well they would act as it was like you
see he does the dishes
and they always have family so it's more
about like the family dynamic of like
they would be there did they sleep in
the same bed
i don't think so they didn't cover that
aspect but i found that the most
interesting aspect
easy yoko yoko's interest wow um
pure spouses we just watched the mormon
documentary
really good it's called murder among
mormons on netflix really good
what is what's it about i haven't even
heard it it's like there was
in salt lake city there was there's time
when people were collecting all these
ancient mormon
ancients like 150 years or artifacts and
then
uh the people who were close to this
whole ring started getting blown up
like bombed and murdered and there's a
whole really
crazy story that unfolds from it with
the church and all these
crazy people really interesting good
yeah really good four parts on netflix
three three searching scotty was worried
about me
defamatory statements
all right let's continue
what's your favorite crazy christian
video video
i have no idea i'll go first and we were
outside one day
youth group and uh he was just just
trying to push my buttons and he was
just you know
kind of not taking the lord seriously
and i walked over to him and i went
and punched him in the chest as hard as
i crumpled the kid
the kid i just got down and i said
i think nobody said ben when are you
going to stop playing games with god
right there there's times that that
might be sorry
what's your favorite crazy christian did
you just admit to punching a child in
the chest his heart
i crumpled that kid i'll proudly for the
congregation
i laid that [ __ ] kid out that [ __ ]
kid
out
isn't that god's job like why do the you
better you
if you don't fear god you'll fear me boy
oh god it's so crazy i gotta watch that
again i love how he just
he's so proud of himself i'll go first
and we were outside one day youth group
get away with that
just trying to push my butt
he said he punched a child as hard as he
[Laughter]
could
we brought him to god by that he means
he yeah
he died he didn't [ __ ] around anymore he
sent him to heaven
damn dude that's great quit playing
games with god
there's a lot of these cross
what's your favorite crazy crazy
christian from different people
the same this is a tick tock meme where
i think this guy started the trend and
then everybody like
touches it yeah yeah so this guy
this happens on tick tock all the time
there's like this there's people that go
like mega viral for some stupid clip
they made like there's this girl
what's your favorite celebrity interview
moment like this small account nobody
girl
who's now been seen like a trillion
times don't take that what just like my
whole feeling what's your favorite
celebrity interview moment
what's some of the other ones ab there's
another one that's super popular
oh what a celebrity what's the celebrity
that people tell you look like
wow that's why i say that what this is
the one what's your favorite celebrity
interview
moment i'll go first i hate when they
say i'll go first like they're trying
sword to make a trend
i'll go first but
i hate that
[Laughter]
it's they were like huge artists and
they lost their whole career because
they were you know
so-called exposed for essentially having
ghost writers and
and uh people make their music in the
studio
the truth is it's like halfway hold on
hold on hold they didn't sing
right you're right well that's that's
not what happens people sing their songs
somebody else is saying their songs
right i guess that's true that's what
that is
they were exposed for it yeah because
they won like all these awards and they
were like this huge thing they did
and they were insane they won grammy's
someone else yeah
they they didn't sing the [ __ ] song
no that's weird yeah that's weird then
come on it was two
i think it was two german guys that was
behind it all right yeah
believe it
that they just straight up denver and
they didn't couldn't they
didn't sing someone else's voice yeah
they just like performed
they are like lip sinkers and they would
dance and perform but it like wasn't
actually them i mean it's a good idea
yeah it didn't work though something
tells me that happens
more than we know i don't that's pretty
extraordinary dan i don't think so
i don't know i'm gonna push back on that
one
damn video
thank you zack
they put a lightsaber
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this
excuse me there's somebody talking
there's music blasting the video is tiny
what is going on here
could somebody find a video where he has
a lightsaber oh yeah
right i think we're seeing that
what are we gonna do what does the text
even say six tubby tubby then walked off
like a ghee
what's your favorite question i don't
know what to say about that one
oh we got the uh lightsaber one here we
go somebody chat saying dan's right
britney doesn't sing a lot of her songs
it's not proven though
they got smarter about it who are we
talking about i'm assuming britney
spears
britney does this just some random
[ __ ] comments that could be wrong
sorry that's a huge scandal yeah how
dare you free britney
a lot of very big artists like they
don't sing every song on
in the concert because they need to
catch their breath and whatnot so some
of them different though
someone else saying yeah that's millie
wasn't even on
the studio version was the thing but
again oh yeah
people saying it's proven people say
proven knowledge
what i just said about it
how dare you leave brittany alone all
right to defend dan to defend that baby
live
she has been caught lip syncing live
well everybody lips things like that
exactly what we're talking about
we're talking about someone else
completely singing their song everybody
lip syncs live
no they i mean no with the i mean
exception of auto tune which everyone
does no it's britney
okay that's what we're talking about
[Applause]
there's like a crazy reverb on that one
[Music]
oh whoa oh i gotta mute it
because i don't want to get george
george lucas has enough money he doesn't
need
the revenue that's great
[Laughter]
yeah it's like literally doesn't look
any different
it doesn't look any different
yeah dude this guy's having so much fun
up there
he'll demons i command thee
[Laughter]
by the way some of these people are old
and they're just piling on each other
oh no he's a sith lord they're like free
falling on their back
not a sith lord i knew you
all right moving on
what then you got britney [ __ ] what's
your favorite favorite
so they're saying even saying the name
but her name is maya marie
look into it who's this maya marie what
liver alone
crazy christian video i got you
now this is a physical illustration to
show you when cody puts
on the word of god it literally is a
protective barrier around his mind
with the helmet of salvation and
thinking
on things that are heavenly and this is
what the mind is
saying your mind or your affections on
things
above you throwing eggs at your home and
look nothing
can penetrate cody's mind
i love that they're like you a good
christian's mind should be unpenetrable
where is he wearing a helmet right
exactly
that's what god is semen is is another
kind of milk
[Laughter]
[Music]
my favorite one's not here yet the
atheist is your favorite crazy chris
christian video
shut up your dad [ __ ] mouth you fool
god damn you forever to attend
[Music]
[Music]
what is this is this real i feel like
this has to be fake
oh [ __ ] all righty
what's your favorite crazy christian
video
[Music]
why don't you just turn over to your
neighbor i want you to find a drinking
buddy
i need to reach over
well what i i want you just to find
their vein
what you guys done
and i just want you to shoot them up
jesus on in line
and they'll share the favor
god is dumping out the glory should be
booby juice
just started talking the ghost
what is this
baby too there's certain powers
i think we're getting played here it
seems like stand up come on my favorite
crazy
uh interview celebrity interview moment
i mean that's not what that's not the
trend we're doing the atheist
nightmare i mean this is such a classic
but man these guys are such [ __ ]
idiots
you've seen this right yeah oh yeah
behold the atheist behold nightmare now
if you study a well-made banana you'll
find on the far side
there are three ridges on the close side
two ridges
if you get your hand ready to grip a
banana you'll find on the far side
there are three grooves on the close
side two grooves the banana and the hand
are
perfectly made one for the other you'll
find the maker of the banana almighty
god has made it with a non-slip
surface it has outward indicators of
inward contents green
too early yellow juice
if you go to the top of the banana
you'll find as with the soda can makers
they placed a tab at the top
so god has placed a tab at the top when
you pull the tab
the contents don't squirt on your face
you'll find the wrapper which is
great has perforations notice how
gracefully it sits over the human hand
gracefully
just the right shape of the human mouth
it's chewy easy to digest
it's even curved toward the face to make
the whole process so much easier oh yeah
seriously kurt the whole of creation
testifies to the genius of god's
creative heart
it absolutely does the atheist well so
if the banana is so perfect are we meant
just to eat bananas
like what about every [ __ ] food then
how about it i mean
did anybody nobody pointed out to him
that bananas are uh
are like a domesticated like we created
bananas right they don't exist
naturally well like i'll tell
hold on he created us so we domesticated
it but that's very funny that yeah we
we of all the things he could have
chosen yeah
that was like one of the worst ones you
could have picked yeah because it's
domesticated
but it's a nightmare it's the easiest
nightmare you cannot respect this
i heard one of these guys say well it
fits perfectly in your butt too does
that mean that god decided to do that
yeah fits perfectly
over your hands the god's aeronamic
design
slides perfectly in your mouth
something is about to bust anything else
you guys want to talk about while we're
here
no i don't know if i'm ready for soaking
in the same episode as
the chat has been spamming for the last
like 15 minutes talk to horse guy
i have no idea what you guys i don't
know what i'm talking about
when you guys spam stuff like that you
like if you don't give context
it's not helpful talk to horse guy
are they talking about the old h3 video
guy i have no [ __ ] clue
does it we haven't even talked about
horses today like what
nobody requires
no bucket required um
that's pretty much all i don't i don't
think we should do the suit soaking in
this thing
i'm gonna save that one all right but if
there's is there any interesting
comments or donations or anything you
guys want to talk about before we
say can we just do all update
on um you actually sent this this was
your suggestion ethan so
we just oh i sent the wrong thing hold
on
why did you just send me a giant jaw guy
dan because that's just
saying that there's
yeah this is my homie my jaw guy that
everyone was laughing about now he's
become a meme i saw him on twitter
people posted this before and after and
like what the [ __ ] is this
this is my homie that i'm just
fascinated by this guy's jaw routine and
everyone's clowning on me look at that
guy
he's turning into a [ __ ]
i mean he doesn't look real this is
unreal
stop the training
stop the training don't stop bro just
keep going take it all the way
i say take it all the way until your
face is literally just
it's just it's just gonna be like i
don't know it's gonna be a square
it's gonna be a triangle
yeah let's check in with our dog
[Music]
i can't listen to your music bro one two
let's hit those jaws
dude if i saw that guy i would like do a
double deck not because he's handsome
but i'd be like what the [ __ ] did i just
see
but sometimes it doesn't look that weird
you know
well i guess in the earlier videos
i don't know what's going on he's
man okay i'm out
that was it that was all you want me to
talk about is jaw guy
uh there's a bunch of good stuff in here
it's just a shame
there it is i guess we can save it what
did you mean maybe scotty at 235
uh 2.35 on wikifee
poor scotty we love scott i mean
[Music]
i mean he was once loved he was once
loved he once had a great score and
wiggy
threw it all away he'd do it all the way
he did an oopsie
you're very special can we jam out to
ila song
no no we're not ready what about um
i saw you guys mention the r kelly
passport song oh that's a good way to
sign off
you know it's been a while since we've
watched the r kelly do you have your
passport do you have your shots and
we're thinking it's just ridiculous that
you know this is somehow become old news
yeah r kelly to you so i thought maybe
also everybody's spamming bad baby in
the chat
oh yeah so you're not you're not clueing
us into anything we're aware
oh well i might as well just explain
what happened yeah um well she tweeted
she sub-tweeted me and followed me
saying that she had a story about david
and i'll show that here's somebody link
me a tweet
and um i followed her and said hey what
happened and she didn't respond so
i don't know and she's tweeted since
then too so she clearly saw my
message so kind of confused
about uh why she tweeted at me
or she just tried to be funny i don't
know she said i got my own story about
those two creepy [ __ ] and he owes me
money
this girl's such a character you know we
were talking about her she was 12 when
she was on dr phil
and when she collaborated with them she
was like 13 or something right
that is crazy yes we found
there was a deleted vlog with her um
that we found where it's just basically
jason bantering with her and like
i wouldn't say creepy but just it's just
a like
it's a 13 year old yeah it's like a 45
year old man like doing bands
yes it's very weird i understand why
they delete it it's like pretty cringe
i remember i don't know if this is
public or if david but
i don't remember where i heard this but
he like paid her a bunch of money to do
it
and then but she says they owe her money
i don't know i don't know but she never
responded trust me i wanted to [ __ ]
know too
you know dying you know
yeah i was just like what is this giant
t-ship i loved it
yeah i love this yeah no i don't think
so
okay nobody knows who david heart is we
do need that cop
though who knows that nobody knows david
lieberhart
he's a legend okay so r kelly
went to by the way
not to draw extreme parallels but
there's plenty of arkell girls who
didn't leave r kelly immediately so
you wouldn't ever say to them i mean
different situations but you never say
to them
why didn't you leave sooner why don't
you go to the police sooner
why didn't you do this why are you that
here's our people do say that it's just
right he wouldn't say that to them but
people do say that to them you're right
people say they've been saying that for
basically ever yeah
here's our kelly in ethiopia recruiting
sex slaves basically on stage
i got it i got it i got it do you have
your passport
did you get your shots girl would you
like to come back
[Applause]
[Music]
did you get your shots would you like to
come
[Music]
back
nothing more romantic than that did you
get your shots girl
i'm ready to get my shots and hop on a
plane with him it's it's probably the
best song ever
dude straight up dude he took grooming
to leveled nobody he's straight up
grooming people on stage during the show
that is next [ __ ] level there's no
deception in this
he says girl you cannot you need your
shots this is ethiopia you need your
shots and
your [ __ ] passport if you're coming
to an r kelly show bring your passport
already with you
bring your back we're living come back
it's so awesome this is like the
greatest [ __ ] video on the internet
straight up
period
it's so romantic
i got it i got it someone's like hey
give that talk about the we need
something back
i got this they have a whole beach for
grooming
a whole really beautiful view about how
great you have your passports
did you get your shots this summer
didn't make it to an album i love that
look like yeah
oh
okay okay that's a lot more than i asked
for
thank you seaman is is another kind of
milk all right let's
end off with joel let's see what joel
has to say about all the topics of today
you wanted affirmation an inspiration or
a sermon
i want to be inspired yeah yeah
okay emily
worry will keep you from rising high i
can't get over how good the speaker
keeps you from pursuing dreams
going around offended bitter will keep
you from new opportunities
yeah why do all these people hurt me
they did me wrong that's why i'm bitter
that's why i'm upset that happened 27
years ago
why are you still holding on to it why
are you still sour over the person that
walked away
still upset over how you were raised
feel bitter over that company that let
you go
don't be a hoarder don't let that poison
your future
they hurt you once don't let them
continue to hurt you
by holding on to it recognize that joel
austin's
basically saying get over it break them
shaving
saying get over it loser get over your
[ __ ] dumb dumb
don't hold on to don't be a loser
god hates losers let it go
you [ __ ] pathetic loser
you can't let your trauma go you're a
loser and god hates you
amen what then
oh this is this is unrelated but uh have
you seen
everybody's upset that the new at the
new space jam
oh is it out no but like i guess there's
a trailer for it or something and they
they made the they made the girl
not hot it's not hot anymore dude well
let me let me see let me
let me be the judge of that okay because
maybe i'll still smash so people are
upset
about what they changed it yeah they
changed it from sexy to strong i
remember reading
that old bunny was [ __ ] slamming
though
show me those before and afters let's
get to the bottom of this you guys got
it what are you guys
getting me to give me the good stuff the
lola bunny
porn i got a really good one i know
someone who's upset about it let me find
out how long
oh was it the quartering by chance uh
probably no not the quarterback but it's
probably
oh j station gay station's got something
to say about this
jay station coming out with some really
strong takes here clown world
no new normal i'm down to move to china
now okay well bro just because they
changed your cartoon
why she's pretty cute still wait what
that there's no problem
well she was like a sexy like icon like
a midriff
she was like roger rabbit hot you know
what i mean like
[ __ ] yeah i would like take i would like
[ __ ] i would do
unspeakable things yeah she's still hard
just like a little more realistic it's a
little more kid-friendly honestly
on the right yeah it's nothing to move
to china about for sure
[Laughter]
she's so [ __ ] beautiful i mean oh the
quartering did have a [ __ ] tweet
about it i knew that the
of course he does oh rejection identity
embrace
tradition bro it's not that serious
jesus
that's a meme he might be actually
goofing although it's him so probably
not
but what is he i mean i'm deep
undercover why would anyone be upset
over this
come on well i you know back when we
were kids cartoons were hot you could
definitely
beat off to cartoons they still are
there's plenty of hot characters
all over everyone look at her curves
relax crazy on the left
it's kind of if you might have that
character just go look at everywhere
if i can be honest the surprising thing
for me looking at this is how curvy the
one on the left was back in the day
yeah you know
i'd [ __ ] i just peed in my basement
if that rabbit came into our life elo
i'm sorry but i love that these are guys
complaining
of course it is nope oh another
according to you
what do you think the crossover is
between cancel culture foot soldiers oh
is he calling wait
he's responding he's calling us i'm not
sure
i'm not i can't make myself wait but
boys just diseased so weirdly
but do you think a crossover between
cancer culture foot soldiers and
sufferers of what is tds
uh that is trump derangement
is what uh people like him use that i'm
deep undercover
it's like 60 70 it's very insightful
i am of course a white supremacist
hey listen quartering no hard feelings
buddy
i just am wondering you know
if you use if it's 3 a.m and you're it's
the middle of the night and you have to
go to the bathroom
where are you gonna go i just peed in my
basement in the basement you would go
all the way to the basement to do that
nothing maybe i'm gonna pee in my trash
can down here i don't know right trash
can makes money you don't want to
disturb your wife probably that's the
biggest concern
right i'm not taking a pause
of course not would never dream of
asking such a thing of you
my wife went out for pizza without me i
know that was a big issue in your
marriage that's not cool dude
not cool i would never do that to you
yeah i know that's why we have such a
happy marriage
i knew something was up oh we have
another quartering tweet all right let's
just turn let's just go
i'm sorry you go through his whole
twitter how are you going to do my girl
like this bree like this
everyone in these should be recalled oh
he's just mad that it's like
not a yeah oh okay i honestly
don't think you could find another
channel that praises brie larson
as much as me okay good
all right that's it right that's all
everybody's asking for an update on keto
there's no keto there's no diet
dude i got super frustrated because i
was in it for two weeks and i was
and i gained two pounds and i was like
[ __ ] this
so i'm having a cheat week i'm
celebrating so i told ethan
why don't you follow me um and eat
what i'm eating wouldn't that be fun if
we
tried it for half a day you didn't even
give me a shot
you just ate my breakfast and then you
were done ela with pizza which you said
was good
with peace and love for well then you
pulled out a chocolate and i couldn't
have any of that so what is it am i on
your diet or no
either goes well okay okay you're doing
like you're doing my diet
i'm gonna eat this chocolate but you
can't have it i was like who's diet are
we doing
my diet so why don't i get a cake that i
dictate for you i'm eating fatty you're
[ __ ] guru okay i'm over
it and i'm not gonna talk about it
anymore you do whatever you want yeah i
know it's exhausting for you to deal
with it i know
but you just trust the process i trust
everything i'm just
out i'm taking a weekend off it's not in
a bad or a good way i'm just not going
to talk no i don't
know just do whatever you want
i had some [ __ ] bagel pizza bagels
this weekend i was like
[ __ ] this pizza or like i was like [ __ ]
this
they bought or we bought like pizza
bagels for theodore i'm like [ __ ] this
i'm eating his bat dumb bagel it's no
it's a little bitter bites
you stole your son's pizza yeah i stole
all theodore's pizza bagels
i'm literally stealing my ice cream too
i'm elazie and i'm awful
i love pizza and i love people papa tell
you
that what if pizza is pizza's healthy
right this is totally healthy i believe
i'll tell you a puppy pizza is actually
very nutritious yeah what's the problem
yeah pizza tonight i've had over 40
pizzas in the last come on look at
poppy's in great shape
papa isn't great
come on now but it's not a pizza bagel
it is it's a little bagel if you look on
the back yeah it's a little bagel
i don't know that's the bagels cute yeah
this is all the farts they're pretty
good i'm not gonna hate on the pizza
bagel i was like this is pretty [ __ ]
good you have pizza in the morning pizza
in the evening
oh bro they would go pizza in the
morning
pizza in the evening pizza at some kids
summer time
why is there like pizza for every meal
now when pizza is on a bagel you can
have pizza
anytime right because it's on legos
breakfast pizza on the bag
i love that that was papa
papa was behind that [ __ ] that turns me
on
all right that's it i'm listening i came
out here i want to talk to address the
scotty thing
we've talked a lot more than i wanted
then i explained to so i don't have that
much more planned
let's all go listen to elton john
separately
here's another song that i was thinking
about in relation to that
someone saved my life tonight
you had your hooks in me didn't you
you nearly had me roped and tied
honestly the witch song is better for
the situation
that or well i feel like sugar bear was
more about like domestic abuse where
oh no i was sorry was more about a
breakup no i was
going to say that or did you bring your
passports
did you give you a shot yeah definitely
yeah
you know what's really cool my mom got
vaccinated she's like both shots both my
parents were yeah both shots vaccinated
so like you can see my parents now i'm
starting to feel
a little less pressure because i would
be so paranoid for everyone around us
like
i don't want to cause something for
someone else so
it's your parents and our nanny and like
all this stuff so
so many people around us are finally
getting vaccinated yeah it's great
just feeling a little less pressure
oh was it kenneth though i think kenneth
dick is responsible for the
lowering cases kenneth copeland of
course
so that's awesome so i can see my
parents on the weekend like we used to
which is really nice i mean we didn't
see them for a long last time
i can't wait to get it myself stick me
with that [ __ ] bro
like a like a shot of botax to wendy
william's face
[Laughter]
all right that's it guys so have a great
listen make me one promise
foot soldiers have a great weekend
yeah have a great [ __ ] weekend
right is that it that's the one and um
well yeah i mean that's pretty
open-ended like you can kind of build
your
own uh truth in within that
you know what i mean build your own
truth
and build your own truth so that's it
there's another kind of milk that's okay
that's your truth dude
speaking right that's his truth speak
his truth
um
thank you guys for tuning in and and
hearing it out you know
this is an important conversation
actually i think i really do think it's
an important conversation so i'm glad we
were able to come out here and express
ourselves
and for you all to be here
[Music]
listen listen and participate so god
bless
um god bless
uh there's something else i want to say
but it's evading me so i guess it wasn't
that important
other than just foot soldiers assemble
thank you for answering the call of war
the war horns were blown and uh
everybody
rolled up so thank you guys
[Music]
what else i thought there was something
else i i i have
my mouth is empty what else what else
we'll be filming jewish trivia do we
have any leads on the hasid outfits
the orthodox outfits
you're
ian is semen milk yes or no
[Music]
um i don't know do we have any sort of
sound bite that might inform me on
this one no okay never mind
semen is is another kind of milk
i was just letting the awkwardness
linger great
all right okay anyway that's that thank
you guys once again we'll see you
on tuesday with a very new episode of
the h3 podcast we appreciate y'all we'll
see you next time did you say that i'm
gonna start not being in the middle of
the week episode i said that in the
middle of the week episode
but i'll say today ila with peace and
love has too much to do
love either will not be on the thursday
wednesday episodes anymore with peace
and peace
so any requests for you to be on the
show i'm gonna say will be tossed
i'm gonna be going into the teddy fresh
world fully
which is uh gonna be a big change for me
because
it's been really hard to juggle both
like when we do the podcast it kind of
takes
most of my day and then i would try to
get to teddy fresh after but it's like
it's really hard
um so i'm just going to be only on
fridays
which is i think it's cool anyway
because ethan will have
an episode alone i'll have my own day to
get cancelled
that was the joke everyone was saying
which is true whenever i'm without you
it goes off the rails
you know well within the first 10
minutes of the episode we were talking
about genital mutilation
nice right i was thinking what did you
guys think about a title for the my
alone episode now it's like off off the
rails without
ela with ethan klein maybe a little
longer
it'll be like off the rails without hila
klein with ethan klein podcast yeah
because if i ever get cancelled for
something i say that i'll be like hey
it's off the road
you promise you have a good weekend
bye bye bye bye bye tata
bring your passport next time
you're watching three h233
watching h to the three three three
three you're watching h to the three
three three
three you're watching h two three three
[Music]
you